we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
um i got a lot of voicemails about cpac
a few dozen of them i'm going to play
one for you here
and you may have noticed that the sort
of slogan or motto for cpac this year
the conservative political action
conference was america
uncanceled and this is referring to a
couple of different things uncanceled in
terms of
the right has seen covet guidelines
as not public health uh
needs but rather as the cancellation of
american people of american business etc
so
cpac uncanceled in one way means the
uncancelling of things that were
cancelled due to
covid they also are now waging this
so-called war against cancel culture so
so kind of a double meaning here's a
voicemail i got
about really what they mean by cancel
culture take a listen to this
hey david adam from layton utah here
yes i want to say that
cancel culture is really just another
form of
victimhood from the uh
right-wing conservatives in america
and who what's going on there why are
they
why does victimhood appeal so much
i don't know help me make sense of this
thing yeah i i don't know about
victimhood is so appealing to the right
victimhood is useful to the right and
if you listen to donald trump's cpac
speech yesterday
if you listen to donald trump's entire
presidency and
everybody around him and right-wing
media for a party
and a political movement that has
claimed for decades to be about
personal responsibility the degree to
which they have made themselves
the victims of everything is quite
stunning it really is
donald trump has been treated unfairly
by the media
the right has been treated unfairly by
public health officials it's all
they are the endless uh victims
all the time and i i
from a psychological standpoint i'd be
interested to learn more about what it
is that makes it appealing to them i
think it's politically useful
i think right-wing elected officials
republican elected officials have
realized
that particularly the the sort of
right-wing populists
that the rhetoric of victimhood about
how
they are trying to fight for you but
everybody's attacking them
it fits in very neatly with this
right-wing populist faux populist
rhetoric
that they endlessly repeat and promote
even though it links in absolutely no
way to the actual policies that they put
forward so for me it's more about
political utility
and they've been self-victimizing when
it comes to how they're being treated
on social media networks ignoring that
the stuff that's in violation of the
terms of service is coming
overwhelmingly from them they ignore
that they look only
at a sort of consequences-based approach
and then of course what that gets you to
is they believe they should be free of
consequences there shouldn't be any
consequences
to the things that they do or the things
that they say and any consequences to
their speech or actions by definition
are them being attacked but this
unfortunately because this has worked so
well at building
uh of this this very strange political
coalition that now exists on the right
because it's worked well i i expect it
to stay for a long time
um but i'm curious to hear from people
in the audience psychologically what
makes this vic
victim is self-victimization so so
appealing
is there something beyond just its
utility that makes it appealing
we have a great bonus show for you today
speaking of cancel culture we will talk
about the latest weapon in the culture
wars
mr potato head yeah we'll also talk
about
some very interesting new studies
relating to
uh dreams and the meaning and
significance of dreams and utility
and also we will talk about the doctor
fired after giving away expiring doses
of the covet vaccine i got a trash
what i call a trash vaccine i rescued a
dose from the trash by being on an
on-call list
i got my second dose friday um a doctor
was fired
for making use of those about to be in
the trash vaccines we will talk about
all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com